-It is the end of the week,
and that's usually
when I catch up with some
personal stuff.
You know, I check my inbox,
I return some e-mails
and, of course, I send out
thank-you notes.
Well, I was running a bit behind
today, so I thought,
if you guys wouldn't mind,
I'd just like to write out
my weekly thank-you notes
right now.
Is that --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You guys are the best.
James, can I get some thank-you
note writing music, please?
♪♪
There it is.
It looks like he's got secrets.
♪♪
Thank you, "Bachelorette"
getting replaced,
for only being the second most
famous reality TV star
to lose their job this week.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, Steve Kornacki
and John King,
for being the McSteamy
and McDreamy of touchscreens.
[ Applause ]
I love everyone's so impressed
with the touchscreen.
My daughter was using
a touchscreen at six months.
She was...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, red mirage,
for sounding less like
a political term
and more like
the 14th Marvel movie
to get postponed this year.
[ Applause ]
"Red Mirage."
♪♪
Man, this one's --
You might want to help me out
on this one.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. I get to phone a friend
on this one.
-Okay.
Try it out.
-Yeah, just laugh
even if it's not funny.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-It's pretty good.
All right, we'll see.
-Wait, right now? Or --
-What?
Yeah, now.
Well, after I'm done.
-Okay.
-After I'm done with the joke.
[ Laughs ] That was funny.
-Wait till --
I didn't do it yet, but once
I do it, then you do it.
Okay, here we go.
-Okay.
-Almost.
♪♪
Thank you, Drake's
new Alpine Yodels,
for not going by your
original name, Yeti Turds.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait.
What?
[ Laughter ]
-What? That was the original
name they went with?
-Ah.
-I don't know, man.
[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
Thank you, fancy wine openers,
for making my guests think
that I'm either
a wine connoisseur
or a steampunk alcoholic.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, owls,
for always looking like you just
read Don Jr.'s latest tweet.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, election week,
for hopefully coming
to an end,
and for letting us all go back
to a calm, relaxing life
of worrying about
a global pandemic.
There you go. Those are
our thank-you notes.